[Música]
cuando la gente se entera que yo soy vih
positivo lo primero que me preguntan es
y como te lo agarraste muy agradable no
me da mucha tranquilidad me preguntan
cómo te agarraste claro porque soy por
la vida agarrando virus como si fuesen
pokémons
tildando no me preguntan de la
transmisión no me preguntan eso yo en
general lo que optó por responder es
fácil un fluido infectado sobre mismo
cosas ah no perdón que esperabas que te
cuente cómo tenían sexo con mi pareja yo
ahí la gente reacciona algunas dicen me
diste luca siempre se enoja el tan
capricorniano muy de la performance y
otro me dicen que mala persona tu ex k
me preguntan si ustedes como tenían
relaciones se habían testeado sabían
conocían los medio de transmisión como
eran o eso no me lo preguntan me
preguntan cómo te lo agarraste
y yo me pregunto cómo es que viene
alguien y así de la nada piensa que yo
no tengo ningún tipo de valor que yo no
puedo ser susceptible o estar mal que yo
le tengo que responder cuánto vale mi
cuerpo vih-positivo en esta sociedad
un amigo me contó en esta sociedad tan
capitalista todos tenemos un valor y
todo se maneja como si fuesen
transacciones de compra de venta
en base a ese valor después veremos qué
amigos que empleo que trabajo tendremos
se llama
suele hay mucho material al respecto
durante el iii pues teníamos palabras
dificilísimas
pero les cuento cómo lo llegué a
comprender saben que me imaginé me
imaginé como si nosotros fuésemos latas
en una gran góndola
no va agarró una lata
y en ataque tiene una etiqueta muy bella
muy photoshop ya mucho filtro de
instagram
y después estamos los humanos
di vuelta esa lata y vi los ingredientes
a ingredientes le corresponde un valor
ingredientes tales como esto empleo
formación académica donde naciste color
de piel belleza que tan hegemónica tu
belleza que tan cercana al estereotipo
alcanzar y cada uno de estos
ingredientes tenía un valor si sumamos
todo ese valor dado el valor de esta
lata
primero un poco de miedo dije cómo es
esto
a ver
yo que soy considero lindo
tengo una belleza
pero qué pasa mi belleza no alcanza para
hacer una lata premium una alcanza los
estándares que hay que tener para llegar
más alto yo también considero que tengo
una vida social una vida profesional
pero claro después me meto en instagram
y no tengo una oficina tan shen no tengo
ensaladas tan alegres para comer las
riéndonos y son tan fotogénicas yo
también tengo una gata
mi gata se llama de murcia
y miga tyson
fíjate yo aprendimos que no somos tan
fotogénicas que no somos con estos
perros cara chata solemnes divinos que
cosechan tantos like no con la lengua
dijimos bueno esto es lo que nos queda
entonces me di cuenta que el valor de
mis ingredientes lo ponía la otra edad
se dan cuenta de esto los otros son
quienes definirán cuánto valemos en este
mercado de los vínculos del empleo los
otros nos ponen el valor
entonces dije no basta y fui por el lado
del body positivo puedo decir mi cuerpo
vale soy lindo soy guapo y me saqué un
montón de selfish muchas muchísimas
mucho filtro de instagram
mucho y salí a la calle
y me di cuenta de que tampoco alcanzaba
porque vi el primer comercial tan
hegemónico solemne bello dije yo no
tengo nada que ver con eso entonces me
metí en un cine y estuve dos horas
viendo una película en la que el
objetivo era estar en pareja y jayko mi
soltería
tratando de abrazarla y decir está bien
que esté soltero pero no la película me
enseñaba de que no está bien mi soltería
la publicidad me enseñó que no estaba
bien mi belleza las redes sociales me
enseñaron que no que no alcanzaba nada
de lo que yo estaba haciendo y saben que
yo fui volvía a la góndola y agarré cada
una de esas latas y las abrí y me di
cuenta que estaban todas vencidas
abolladas también que tenían las
etiquetas corridas me di cuenta que la
foto con más de 1000 likes también se
sentía fea que la pareja con muchísimas
muchísimas muchísimas fotos deportadas
recorriendo el mundo también se llevaban
mal yo fui agarré esas latas y descubrí
que los perros esos tan solemnes y
bellos en personas muerden
me di cuenta de que todas todos todos
estábamos saben que en bancarrota
emocional que teníamos una parrilla
llena de vacío existencial
en cuenta eso que estábamos todos todos
rotos y fui muy feliz o sea me fui feliz
sabiendo que estaban todos mal
[Aplausos]
acá pasa un poco no se queme en cuenta
que estamos aspirando estamos aspirando
a un estereotipo inexistente y real que
nos median valores inalcanzables
pero claro mi lata la lata del fauno
tiene un sticker que dice vih incluido
y por ese sticker pareciera que valgo
menos que pueden venir y preguntarme si
cuando te vas a morir
gracias o que vienen y me pueden
preguntar cualquier cosa como si yo no
valiera pero claro este tipo de
preguntas
por ejemplo agarro otra lata no se la
hacen
la lata que es varón sis género
heterosexual clase media-alta
pongámosle un nombre hasta la tapa
pincho dale
a la lata pincho no van y le preguntan
si y tu mamá se sintió muy mal cuando le
contaste que eras heterosexual
a la larga team solo le preguntan si
esos músculos esa cabellera rubia de
elfo fuiste al médico a ver qué onda
a la lata tincho jamás le preguntan y
como te agarraste todos los privilegios
pero claro cuando agarramos una lata
gorda por ejemplo cualquiera va y le
pregunta si será sano te hiciste ver
cuando agarramos una lata que es usuaria
de silla de ruedas le preguntan como si
nada sin tener en cuenta su valor y de
las piernas para bajo os sentís algo
cómo es que podemos ir y pensar que esas
personas que nosotros no valemos
cuando me vienen y me preguntan de la
nada así como te agarraste vih
yo sé que ahora es la parte de la charla
ted donde yo tengo que dar un consejo
revelador y bueno no tampoco no va a
pasar pues sigo siendo de las personas
que están esperando un like para salir
de la depresión
sigo siendo las personas que están
esperando que venga otro a ponerme un
valor alto y en medio de todo eso viene
alguien me pregunta y como te agarraste
vih vamos de vuelta
y porque me lo preguntan amistad y me lo
pregunta porque ser activista porque
perder me lo preguntan porque soy varón
porque soy recito porque tengo una
vivienda porque tengo un empleo me lo
preguntan porque no estoy muerto
lo preguntan también porque esperan que
yo les cuente un pecado que he cometido
lo confiese lo mal que estoy y les
cuente lo bien que esté haciendo las
cosas ahora bueno saben que no
solo tengo vih por mi culpa lo tengo por
mi responsabilidad no tengo nada que
confesar a veces la pasó bien a veces no
tanto esa en que no estoy haciendo las
cosas bien y saben que tampoco está bien
que las personas con vih consiga en este
momento no tengamos una ley a jornada
una ley
que tenga en cuenta los derechos humanos
los derechos laborales que necesitamos
porque no me preguntan si es también de
ley necesita una nueva ley no me
preguntan cómo te agarraste vih yo
pregunto para aquí me preguntan cómo te
agarraste vih me lo preguntan para que
yo les confiese ese pecado mortal y se
puedan sentir lejanos distantes de mí de
mi accionar
pero spoiler aleart la h de vih es de
humana de humano de humanes
el virus de la hb no entra en tu cuerpo
pero amigo soy gay qué onda
antes de preguntar en la cuenta bancaria
como venimos no
y yo de repente voy a un programa de
radio a contar que las personas con vih
ya tuvimos que salir dos veces a la
calle a exigir medicación porque nos
cortaron la medicación y voy al programa
de radio del entrevistador a mí sé cómo
te agarraste vih y voy a un programa de
tele a contar que nos siguen
discriminando que seguimos teniendo
problemas que a veces cuesta y me
preguntan y cómo te agarraste vih y a
veces voy a contar otras cosas a una
nota una raíz como te agarraste vih y
como te agarro a estévez y h me vuelven
a preguntar y saben que lo respondí
tantas veces lo respondí bien lo
respondí irónico lo respondo con un
cómic lo respondo con gif lo respondo de
todas las maneras posibles que saben qué
nunca le pude responder a mi al lucas
que hace diez años estaba en un hospital
abajo de un cartel que decía estudios
para el vih llorando preguntándose che
como llegamos acá
lucas como nos agarramos vih
y acá se los voy a contar y solo se
compartirá ustedes también saben cómo
nos agarramos vih saben cómo te
agarraste vih lucas se lo agarraste el
día que pensaste que no valía pero
agarra hasta el momento de pensar te que
no tenías valor que un no eras tan lindo
como las demás latas entonces como vos
ibas a opinar en cuanto a tu placer en
cuanto al uso de preservativos o no
lo harán en el momento en el que
pensaste que había que estar en pareja
porque si estabas solo si estaba soltero
porque algo estamos haciendo mal
ahí te lo agarraste lucas te lo
agarraste en el momento en el que
pensaste que no valía
lucas nos lo agarramos en el momento en
el que en nuestro grupo de amigos nadie
tenía vih entonces de que te ibas a
cuidar si el virus no existía
pero cuando lo dijimos empezaron a
contarnos que yo también mi mamá mi tía
en ese momento el virus está cubierto
por silencio
lucas nos agarramos vih en el momento en
el que dejamos que de nuestro placer de
nuestra salud de todo eso decidan
nosotros
cuente como me agarré así con esa
palabra vih elevar en el momento en el
que pensé que yo no tenía valor ahora
pregúntense para qué quieren saber
ustedes como el vih
van a salir a marchar cuando a mí me
falte medicación
van a ser empáticos cuando estemos
tristes cuando estemos felices
se van a unir a nosotros cuando seamos
orgullosas y orgullosos como los somos
de vivir con un virus y vivir con tanto
orgullo
más allá de lo vivido más allá de lo
hablado
sólo puedo asignar me en mi valor
y después voy a salir la sociedad me va
a decir que estoy equivocado
tampoco puedo esperar que ustedes vengan
a decirme cuánto valgo porque no sería
mayo
nuestro valor es una construcción
colectiva es una construcción que
depende de todas de todos de todos y
saben una cosa
yo valgo y valgo mucho más de lo que
esta sociedad puede medir y saben algo
mejor
nosotras nosotros nosotros valemos y
valemos mucho
y mucho más
de todos estos parámetros y todo lo que
está asociado
[Aplausos]
[Música]